entonces vamos a seguir viendo ejemplos
ahora vamos a usar fracciones entonces
digamos que tenemos dos tercios y que
queremos elevar dos tercios a la digamos
tercera potencia aunque queremos elevar
dos tercios a la tres lo que vimos es
que hay dos formas de encontrar este
número
la primera de ellas es tomar tres veces
dos tercios aquí está uno aquí está otro
aquí está el último y lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar estos números y lo
que nos queda es dos por dos por dos
eso es ocho entre tres por tres por tres
eso es 27 aunque y aquí estoy
simplemente una multiplicación de
fracción es muy fácil nada más tenemos
que multiplicar los numeradores y nos
queda 8 y multiplicamos los
denominadores y nos queda 27 pero bueno
el chiste
es que la segunda forma de encontrar
este número es empezar con un 1 y a ese
1 multiplicarlo por dos tercios tres
veces o sea tal cual lo que tenemos
escrito por aquí y obviamente nos queda
el mismo resultado aunque y entonces
vamos a ver otro ejemplo vamos a tener
cuatro novenos y lo vamos a elevar a la
potencia 2 aunque cuando tenemos un
número y lo elevamos a la potencia 2
muchísimas veces decimos que estamos
elevando al cuadrado este número aunque
y algo similar pasa con la potencia 3
cuando tenemos un número y lo elevamos a
la tercera potencia decimos que estamos
elevando al cubo a este número ok
esos son los dos casos en los que
tenemos nombres especiales para los
exponentes pero bueno el chiste es que
te recomiendo que le pongas pausa y
encuentres cuánto vale esta cosa tú
solito y ya después le vuelves a poner
play lo que hacemos es que tomamos
dos veces a cuatro novenos aquí está una
vez y aquí está otra vez dos veces
porque el exponente es dos y lo que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar estos
dos números aunque entonces es una
multiplicación de fracciones y nos queda
cuatro por cuatro que es 16
entre denominador por denominador que es
9 por 93 81 y otra vez si hubiéramos
tomado la otra definición lo único que
tenemos que hacer es empezar con un 1 y
multiplicar por 4 novenos dos veces osea
tal cual lo que está aquí y listo ya
sabemos elevar fracciones a distintas
potencias aunque con cualquier otro
exponente es exactamente lo mismo nada
más tenemos que multiplicar más veces
por cuatro números